Майже сорок вісім відсотків українців
вищу освіту - повну, базову або неповну.
Такі дані, які Дойче Велле отримала у Держстаті України
щодо групи населення у віці від чотирнадцяти
до тридцяти п'яти років.
Це не мало, якщо порівнювати з відсотком населення
з вищою освітою передових країн.
Зокрема, якщо відштовхуватися від даних Організації економічного
співробітництва та розвитку - ОЕСР,
до якої належать 35 країн світу,
то виходить, що українці мають на руках більше дипломів,
ніж німці (31%)
італійці (26%)
і навіть австрійці (40%).
Але це не зовсім коректне порівняння.
Адже український Держстат рахував не лише тих,
хто має дипломи магістрів та бакалаврів,
а й  спеціалістів і молодших спеціалістів.
Їх майже половина від загальної кількості людей з вищої освітою.
Натомість ОЕСР
взяла за основу категорію людей -
віком від двадцяти п'яти до тридцяти чотирьох років.
Передові позиції у цьому списку у Південної Кореї,
Росії та Польщі  - 70, 60 та 43 відсотки відповідно.
Щоправда, у випадку з Росією є свої нюанси.
ОЕСР враховує
у відсоток з вищою також і випускників технікумів.
Крім того, звіт базується на даних Росстату.
Щодо якості вищої освіти, то за цим показником
Україна далеко позаду тих країн,
які вона випереджає за кількістю дипломів на душу населення.
Зокрема - на сорок п’ятому місці у світовому рейтингу університетів
QS World University Rankings.
У першій п’ятірці натомість – Сполучені Штати,
Великобританія, Німеччина,
Австралія і Канада.
Що ж впливає на рейтинг якості освіти
і чому Україна не у лідерах?
Для порівняння: в Україні у 2014 році
було у сім разів менше докторів наук, ніж у Німеччині.
Кількість наукових публікацій в Україні
була у 16 разів менша.
А патентів менше - у цілих 24 рази.
Такі дані наводить німецька служба академічних обмінів.